Why can't they live
as you do in this valley?
The ocean winds protect our valley.
The Sea of Decay can't reach us here.
What do you say, Yupa?
Isn't it time you settled in this valley?
Look at my condition.
It would please everyone.
Don't bother.
Yupa's a man who is fated
to search forever.
Fate, huh...
Obaba, what's he searching for?
Oh my, don't you know, Nausicaä?
Look, see the tapestry on the wall...
I can no longer see it.
The figure in the left corner.
"...clothed in blue robes,
descending onto a golden field,
to join bonds with the great Earth
and guide the people to the pure land,
at last."
Lord Yupa,
I always thought that was only a legend.
You mustn't tease me, Obaba.
It's the same thing.
I only wish to solve
the Sea of Decay's mysteries.
Are we humans but a tribe
destined to be swallowed
and ruined by the Sea of Decay?
That is what I wish to know.
If only I could help Lord Yupa...